good morning John it was a year ago that
I decided that I wanted to do a full
year where every month I made a video
about a different weird animal here on
the vlog with this channel for every one
of those weird animals we'd make a pin
people would be able to sign up and get
those pins as I made the videos and we
call it the bizarre beasts pin Club and
this is the twelfth one of those I
really loved this little project inside
a project and we conclude with an animal
that is not an animal so John do you
remember the time when we were kids at
the beach and there was a dead
Portuguese man-of-war and I stepped on
it and I was in Paden for a full day
well because of that I have kind of
always assumed that these animals were
fairly well understood as they are
common they impact people and they are
weird enough that we probably would have
spent lots of time looking and our lack
of understanding of Portuguese
man-of-war isn't really down to a lack
of curiosity it's down to a lack of
sense it is very confusing a Portuguese
Man O'War for example is not an animal
it is for animals this is upsetting
what do you mean Hank somehow for
genetically distinct animals with their
own nervous systems have combined
together to create a single colonial
organism one of them is the stomach one
of them is the gonads one of them is the
floaty part and one of them is the
tentacle part basically there's there's
overlap how much overlap we don't know
how does that overlap function how does
an animal exist with four different
nervous systems and how do those nervous
systems communicate with each other we
don't know this is not how it's supposed
to work but life isn't supposed to work
in any particular way it's supposed to
work in the way that works in the
Portuguese man-of-war as a colonial
siphonophore works even if while
researching this video it forced me to
read sentences like as the organism
grows in the nomada sakkath expands
interior Lee Newton tacular pal ponds
grow at the base of the original gastro
Zoids and these animals are beautiful
well okay sorry these colonial organisms
are beautiful they're also kind of
terrible of course they're predators
they send out their stinging tentacles
up to a hundred and sixty-five feet some
fish however have evolved to be able to
carefully avoid those tentacles or have
some imperviousness to them which allows
them to you
the tentacles of the Portuguese Man
O'War as shelter from larger predator
fish and one species of fish actually is
figured out how to live there and feed
on the Portuguese Man O'War these
organisms are named for the sailing
ships that they very roughly resemble
and they do sail the floaty bit has a
sail on the end of it and that's
designed to have the wind push the
Manowar so that its tentacles stretch
out behind it otherwise the Manowar
would have to swim away from its
tentacles wasting energy they're so good
at catching fish that large colonies can
actually deplete fisheries and the gas
inside of their little bubbles 14%
carbon monoxide so that also could kill
you though you would have to cut it open
and breathe it in a lot which would be
it's questionable questionable
decision-making the variety of ways that
evolution has figured out how to have an
organism survive actually does astound
me it really does this has been such a
fun project and I've enjoyed so much
getting a new pin in my mailbox every
month along with it and I've also felt
kind of limited by the for a minute time
limit of vlogbrothers because like
there's a lot to say about these animals
so so I'm not ending it and I would like
to announce youtube.com / bizarre beasts
a new youtube channel that you can go
subscribe to right now know the thing
that I love to do and I want you to
follow me over to bizarre beasts where
I'll be co-hosting with Sarah sudo one
episode about a weird animal every month
and we will be continuing the pin Club
as well and opening subscriptions to
more people right now if you want to
sign up think that I can have the link
to the pin club and the channel and the
trailer all right here John I'll see you
on Tuesday 10 tacular pal bonds